For commander players who started more
than five or even 10 years ago, do you
remember a feeling that lands used to be
easy? Like we'd stare at non-land cards
for hours trying to figure out what to
add and what to cut, but lands just play
whatever fixing within your budget. Make
sure to save room for basics and toss in
the stable utility lands. You know,
rolly tower, strip mine. I had a friend
who insisted in throwing high market
into every deck. I didn't agree, but
whatever. Those were like free slots
anyways. But from 2019 onwards, things
got crazy fast. Starting with Throne of
Aldrain, which brought us the castles,
and those blew our minds. Little did we
know that was just the beginning. I
mean, back then, we hadn't seen anything
like that since Kamiawa almost. They
produced color, often enter untapped,
and the abilities were widely useful.
They weren't strictly better than
basics, but the risk of making the swap
is fairly negligible. I was excited for
the power up, but had a nagging
discomfort at the back of my mind. I was
kind of hoping this wouldn't be the
norm. Or soon enough, I'll have to I'll
have to use my brain and think about
Lance.
Fast forward to 2025. Now Lance can
transform, tell stories, go mad, work
really hard, and even go on adventures
apparently. Yeah, these Final Fantasy
towns. And this leak is where I finally
lost it. So, you play a forest and I
just I casually drop a planet. Yeah,
seems good. And what is this? It It can
be stationed into a gaas cradle. What
the crap? I need this. But with the
fierce competition, I felt a total
revamp of my land bases was necessary.
And after going through a dozen or so
decks, I had materialized a relatively
intuitive and effective methodology for
myself that is somewhat elegant and easy
to follow. We'll make a tier list for
lands and suggest a step-by-step process
to work our way up the list, picking the
best utility lens while not messing up
our mana producing priority. But before
we get into it, this is Next Level
Commander. I'm Jyn. If you like this
content, please like and subscribe. Let
me know what you think. I try to reply
to every comment. So, which lands should
we pick for our commander decks? Like
spells, we just choose the most
synergistic ones, right? Wrong. Because
again, these are lands, not spells. We
have to go with the ones that are
closest to well basic lands. Yeah,
because fundamentally that's what we're
replacing. Actually, I've seen people
count the MDFC's as spells or half spell
half lands when deck building. I can see
the reasoning, but this actually adds
another massive layer of complexity to
evaluating these cards. Counting them as
lands is where these cards are at their
best due to the near negligible
opportunity cost. Still not clear? There
will be once we go through the tier
list, I promise. Now, this isn't a tier
list for power that's important. It is
for how easy these lands are to include
into a deck. And our first tier is, of
course, just like the basics, ones that
enter untapped and produce color. And
the Neon Dynasty Kamigawa channel lands
are the best of the best. I don't think
this is a particularly controversial
statement. Also, the ones from original
Kamiawa are great, too. Lens like
herborg and Yavi Maya also belong here.
In the same tier, following closely, are
this set of MDFC's that enter untapped
for three life. And for some reason,
this one odd black gate from Lord of the
Rings. The three life may not seem
negligible, but trust me, it is because
you won't be needing it to enter
untapped every game you draw it. For an
educated guess, I'd say you will need
that mana immediately in roughly a third
to half of the games, which means the
actual life cost is somewhere between 1
to 1.5 life per game. That really isn't
much. What makes this tier so special is
that you can play pretty much as many of
them as you want. In 90% of the games,
they will be no different than basics.
Now, following that are these ones that
enter untapped, but dependent on some
minor conditions. For me, these fall
somewhere between tier one and two, 1.5,
I guess. And whether to treat them like
tier one or tier two depends on your
deck. If you have the tools to turn them
on easily and just toss them in. For
example, in a three-color deck with
fetches, shocks, and other lands with
basic land types, we can expect lands
like Dovven Encampment and Mist Village
to almost always be untapped, bringing
them closer to tier one. Now, moving on
to the second tier, we have two kinds of
lands, I guess 2 A and 2B. 2A are the
ones that entertapped
but produce colorless. If you have a
solid argument to convince me why one is
better than the other, I'd love to
listen. For now, we'll just have to
settle for them being kind of equal with
2A being better the more colors your
decks have and vice versa. This is the
most difficult tier to work with because
of the drawbacks can definitely be felt
in games and there's a ton of
competition for a land this tier to be
considered. It needs to provide a lot of
synergy or raw power for this group.
Something like a path of ancestry is a
standout example because of the color
fixing and the scribe can be immensely
helpful in most typo decks. Another
example is Mossword Bridge, which is
ridiculously powerful in any
creature-based build. In terms of
general utility, one of my favorites is
Valica Awakening. This allows us to
cycle everything useless from our hand,
depending on which stage of the game
we're in. And lastly, a personal pet
card, Entangled Florahedron. One of the
most awkward moments with any RAM spell
is when you cast it, but you miss a land
drop. With our Florahedron here, that
will never happen. Either as a trusty
land or a little boost. That is
excellent flexibility in the early game.
Also worth mentioning, the cycling one
options from Lord of the Rings are
functionally tapped lens, tapped dual
lens if you have them in the deck. Dix
makes them really similar to the tapped
two-colored MDFCs for Modern Horizons.
The color fixing is such a massive plus
that they had to keep the front sight
unimpressive. Now, let's talk about the
colorless group, but untapped. From the
old staples, relic tower, I think, is
fairly overrated. I think it was snail
who made an excellent video covering
this. But stripline on the other hand is
only becoming more and more relevant
nowadays with all the crazy lens they've
been printing. Za saga is of course
ridiculous if you have some of the power
trinkets like skull clamp and top
alongside so ringing and core haven is
still holding strong till this day in
any reactive control decks. Scavengers
ground is always great and the new
upster gotment has been an all-star
whenever I drew it. But let's not just
talk about the stables. With all the
options we have now, we can afford to
ditch those for lands that are
specifically synergistic with our decks.
For example, wishes clinic is straight
up color pipe break in my opinion that
can single-handedly solve the life gain
problem if your commander can smack or
burn opponents. I play treasure map in
my mono red deck because it's a burn
deck and it wants to store mana for one
massive turn. And treasure vault can
boost our usable mana by 30 to 40% for
one turn in the late game. Access tunnel
is very cute in some voltron decks
because you can get your commander into
the tunnel first and then pump, equip,
enchant or whatever after. And this is
our tier 2 lens. And from my personal
experience, I wouldn't play more than
eight lands from this group. And again,
how many from each side depends on the
colors. If we are monocolored, I'd feel
a lot more comfortable playing the
colorless options. But in five color,
even one or two, you will feel the hurt
when you draw them. And of course, it
may depend on your deck and commander as
well. For example, if your commander is
the wandering minstrol,
well, you're definitely in the wrong
video. But yeah, no more than eight.
This is the sweet spot I found. And now
we're moving on to tier three lands that
enterta.
Now, this is feeling less and less like
a land. But there's a reason for these
drawbacks. They're powerful. I mean,
Field of the Dead requires no mention,
but Hall of the Bandit Lord and Bichu, I
still find myself playing them in plenty
of decks. Myriad landscape is another
one. for this tier is pretty simple
because there aren't very many options.
There's just the pushed ones that
obviously justify the drawback and then
there's stuff like Cathedral of War,
which we probably shouldn't touch. For
this tier, you probably shouldn't be
playing more than two, which is more
than enough for now because of the lack
of options. And I guess there's
technically a final tier, lands that
don't make mana. They either do nothing
or the most broken crap. not really
relevant to our discussion today because
these should absolutely be taking up
spell slots rather than lens slots. So
now we have our tier list. How do we use
it? We work from the bottom up. Yes, you
heard that right. Starting from tier
three because those are the most
difficult to include and often mean the
strongest payoffs. Let's use a real life
example. How about the new commander
from Edge of Eternities, Kilo Apogee
Mite. A really interesting and
open-ended legendary. I don't want to
build another attraction deck though, so
why don't we try aggro? We can play some
of the modular cards and stuff. I don't
know. We'll see. And we have solid
payoffs like Wave Goodbye, Deming
Verdict, Sagarda Summons, all that good
stuff. Okay, let's go. 38 lands. First,
we're going to need a few basics. Not
too many though, as we won't be playing
too much ramp. Let's say five. Who needs
two mountains? Am I right? Now comes
color fixing. We need some pretty
aggressive fixing in this deck because
while we may not always need to cast our
commander on turn three, we do want to
bring it out soon to start escalating
our board. And before that, we also want
to drop things that benefit from this
proliferate. So, let's go heavy on the
manifixing lens. Let's say 17 of them.
Now, figuring out the ratios and colors
should be in another video by another
YouTuber. I don't know how to fix
colors, man. I just do a third, a third,
a third, even. Done. Now, we have room
for 16 utility lands. So, let's start
from tier three. Two slots. Looking
through the options though, uh it seems
like hollow the bandit lord is the only
one that works with our deck. Giving
haste without costing us tempo every use
is just excellent. We don't need the
ramp from mirrored landscape. Also, not
doing landfall to enable field of the
dead. And I know it's tempting, but I
think we'll refrain from maz's ending
this time. One down and 15 to go. Moving
on to tier two, eight lands. We are
three color and a bit color intensive as
we mentioned earlier. So, let's go
heavier on group A. Let's say a 5-3
split. Starting with colorless, Öza saga
works well with proliferate, and being
able to grab a soul ring or esper
Sentinel just seems too good to pass up.
Nesting grounds a bit slow, but moving
counters on the creatures without them,
like our commander, will allow us to
boost and grow our board so much faster.
Current bastion, another proliferate at
instant speed, will be ridiculous with
the saga creatures that we'll play. And
that's all. I'm sure you may come up
with a set of different lands, but the
key here is we stick to our numbers. All
right, now five from the other group
tapped by colored. We can never have too
many haste neighbors in an aggro deck.
Flamekin village. Let's go. Being able
to clone a creature for three mana seems
excellent and a lot of our plus one
counter creatures scale well in
multiples. And we're going deep into the
MDFCs here because they're just so good.
Legion's leadership being a dual end on
the back is excellent and the front side
is also a decent combat trick with the
way we intend to accumulate counters on
the creatures. This can easily send an
opponent home in the late game. On a
side note, this is also the perfect kind
of MDFC. Early game, you will nearly
always want to play it as a land and
late is always a spell. Unlike, for
example, Maliker Rebirth, it's so good
actually, but I'm always tempted to hold
on to it in the early game, messing up
my rhythm. On Inversion is also great
because of that. The super high cost is
almost an upsight, making sure you don't
have any stupid thoughts in the early
game. Also, suppression ring. Who cares
if we don't have energy? An alpha strike
with this in the late game can easily
steal some wins for us. Also, with Kilo,
we have a set of new gems. The depletion
lens. On paper, these are amazing with
Kilo, but I suspect they may be way
worse in practice. But if we don't try
them here, where else? All right, now we
have eight. And we get to move on to
tier one. And you may have noticed we
only have four slots left. So, we're
just taking the best ones. Arena of
Glory, Aaria's call, Minamo and Castle
Emberth belongs here as well, assuming
we have the support of dual lens and
fetchland. And this is our full utility
land base. Now, this may seem a bit
counterintuitive how our quote unquote
highest tier of lens only has four
entries, but another quick example
should be able to illustrate better why
tier one lands are tier one. Let's take
a Celestnia deck, Yuna, Hope of Spyra. A
Slesnia beatdown deck with enchantment
creatures. Here in two color, the need
to manifix is much lower. Let's say
between basics and manifixing lens, we
are using up just 16 slots compared to
kilos 22. And now for Yuna, we have 22
slots for utility lens. We stick to the
formula. Two from tier three, eight from
tier 2. And now we have 12 more slots.
All of these can be used for tier one
lens. For tier one, we start strong with
BU, Castle, Garen Brig, Monumental Hench
because Sagas, Amarius Call, Turnt,
Timber, Symbiosis, Aenjo. Yeah, you can
see the quality is dropping a bit, but
it doesn't matter. That's the point of
tier one. Play whatever you think feels
right. Shifting woodlands, sure. The
Shire, why not? Kisha Village, Castle
Ardenville because I like the art. Yeah,
you get the point. Tier one cards you
can just play guilt-free without ever
worrying about hurting the groundwork of
your deck. So, there you have it. This
is the rough guideline I use for utility
lands, working our way up the tier list.
Now, I understand that everything is of
course much more nuanced and every
attempt at simplifying the game of
commander into charts, tiers, or
brackets will inevitably fail. But with
what we're doing here, we have our bases
covered. And from there, we can attempt
to reach upwards and make our
customizations. But do remember that
lands are responsible not for the
ceiling, but for the floor of your deck.
Don't mess with it too much or you will
be shooting yourself in the foot. This
is Jyn with Next Level Commander. If you
enjoy this kind of video, please like
and subscribe. How do you play Utility
Lens? Let me know in the comments.